in this video we're going to talk about
something called determinants of
matrices so i'll start just telling you
the notation and how do you compute it
and then we'll think about ways that you
can interpret it
so let's give ourselves a 2 by 2 matrix
here
so and actually i'll give it in general
terms
so let's say that this top left term
here is a
and then this one here is
b the top right
the bottom left is c
and then let's call this bottom right d
and let me do that in a different color
so this is d right over here the
determinant of this matrix so let's
actually let me just call this matrix
let's say that this is matrix a
so there's a bunch of ways to say to
call the determinant or have the
notation for the determinant we could
write it like this we could have these
little it looks like absolute value
signs but it really means determinant
when you apply it to a matrix so the
determinant of matrix a you can write it
that way
you could write it this way the
determinant
of matrix
a
you could write it that way or you could
write it this way where you put these
lines that look like big absolute value
signs instead of the brackets when you
describe the numbers so you could also
write it this way and i haven't
explained what a determinant is or even
how to compute it yet i'm just talking
about the notation of how you even talk
about the determinant
of a matrix
so you could also write it this way just
rewrite the whole matrix with those
vertical bars next to it this is defined
as and we'll see how it's useful in the
future
the top left times the bottom right
so
a
times d
minus
the top right times the bottom left
b
c
so another way to think about it it is
just
these two the product of these two
minus so that's those two right over
there minus
the product of these two right over here
so let's just first before we start to
interpret this get a little practice
just computing a determinant
so let me give you a matrix so let's say
i have the matrix
1
negative 2
3
and 5.
pause this video and see if you can
compute the determinant of this matrix
let's call this matrix b i want you to
figure out the determinant
of matrix b what is this going to be
equal to
all right now let's do this together so
you're going to have the product of
these two numbers
so we have
1
times 5
minus
the product
of these two numbers
which is
3
times negative 2
and that of course is going to be equal
to 1 times 5 is
three times negative two is negative six
but we're subtracting
a
negative six
five minus negative six is the same
thing as five plus six
which is going to be equal to 11.
now that we know how to compute a
determinant in the future video i will
give you an interesting interpretation
of the determinant